benoît hamon une question 1 est-ce que
vous avez été c'est dans votre famille
politique même si en ce moment c'est une
famille compliquée est-ce qu'à l'époque
jce positivement ou négativement à la
publication des photos de ségolène royal
à la maternité qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
et est-ce que vous accepter l'idée et si
c'est pas le cas comment vous allez
lutter conte que demain on vote pour
vous aussi pour ce que vous êtes et à
dire qu'on s'interroge sur votre vie
privée que
là où vous vous présenter aux suffrages
aux électeurs on se questionne sur un
certain nombre de choses qui vous
concerne
sur votre famille sur vous même en
partie donc aussi sur votre vie privée
en deux temps ségolène et vous ségolène
moi je qu'elle a fait ça lui appartient
je pense que c'est n'est pas une
contribution positive à l'image que l'on
restitue de nous en tant que classe
politique puisque nous sommes souvent
jugée comme ci comme ça
manière indifférente parce qu'on a pas
on est élu et je crois pas que ce soit
et d'où les gens n'acceptent dans les
photos elle vous a pas ému quand pauline
homme je pense pas que ce soit très peu
ça lui appartient et je ne crois pas que
ce soit une une très bonne initiative
ensuite sur la vie privée en quoi mes
choix de vie privée affecte-t-il mon
engagement de député européen était mon
mandat en quoi le fait que l'on
connaisse m'accompagne que je met en
scène ma vie privée et ma famille
change-t-il quoi que ce soit la manière
dont j'exerce mon mandat et christophe
barbier a dit quelque chose de très
important il a dit nous savons qu'il ya
des hommes politiques qui ont une double
vie et qui met en scène une vie privée
qui n'est pas tout à fait celle qu'en
réalité ils partagent avec d'autres ou
pas moi je garde ma vie vous a fait ça
et vous à dire aujourd'hui la nouvelle
démocratie implique qu'on en sache un
peu plus elle un fonctionnel sartis
voilà donc on va aller chercher oui bon
on va donc se mettre aujourd'hui aller
chercher les comportements adultérin de
tel ou tel est considéré que parce
qu'ils ont une vie privée qui est une
vie privée pas aussi simple que ce
qu'ils affichent du point de vue de leur
état civil
ça affecte leur mandat et qu'il pourrait
être également des menteurs vis-à-vis
des électeurs c'est ça qu'on insinue est
ce que ça veut dire de moi mais ça
finira par vous arrivez sur votre
candidat dans une mairie vous refuserez
de faire des photos avec votre votre
camp moines votre refuse absolument
d'abord parce qu'elle a son libre
arbitre et elle n'a pas à supporter
l'épreuve que moi je supporte en tant
que j'ai choisie qui est celle d'être
responsables politiques un responsable
politique s'est fait avoir une activité
qui peut être parfois brutales difficile
et ma compagne qui déjà doit supporter
le fait que la politique c'est pas
simple elle n'a pas en plus parce que le
fait qu'elle est mise en scène supporter
cela est encore plus pour mes enfants
et si je vous demande ce soir combien
vous avez des enfants vous ne répondez
pas à si je peux vous dire ma l'état
civil ça ne me gêne pas je peux vous
dire que j'ai une fille mais je vous en
dirais je
je n'en dirai pas plus
[Musique]